l'amour parfait cali
alors ça y est c'est le grand jour tu
t'en vas tu te raccompagne jusqu'à la
porte tu t'en vas regarde tu as devant
toi en grand seigneur au coeur léger
jamais vous envie de tout sauf de te
fait on changeait de projets le sourire
jusqu'aux oreilles de te voir déguerpir
ma vieille alors ça y est c'est le grand
jour tu t'en vas
alors ça y est c'est la bonne cette fois
je regarde tes fesses qui m'échappe et
elles sont pas mal ma foi je te
raccompagne jusqu'à la porte je voudrais
en laye ma joie je voudrais pleurer de
bonheur faire des claquettes sur tes
talons tu ne me prise pas le code non
non non
alors ça y est c'est le grand jour tu
ton va alors ça y est cette fois tu nous
ment pas
sache que c'est dur vient me tirait pas
le moment soit de détresse ouch
c'est quoi si tu reviens souvent et
cette fois
remuez tes fesses ça ne marchera pas
et pons à dire à ta mère que je ne
l'aiment pas n'oublie rien s'il te plaît
casse toi regarde tu as devant toi un
homme absolument ravie j'ai à nouveau
envie de tout sauf de te faire changer
d'avis alors ça y est c'est le grand
jour tu t'en vas
alors ça y est c'est le grand jour là la
mula j'ai tant rêvé cet instant je n'y
crois pas je n'y crois pas sache que ce
soir la seule arme qui coulera c'est ton
nom de tout ce temps perdu avec toi va
donc oms à petit notre débarras
on appelle t-on